[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts I
like short films right so I wrote a
short film I go I think I want to make
you want to do this I have a break in my
tour coming up
and I go it's either this one or this
one so I send them a couple and then I'm
like actually maybe this one
and then I just sent him a bank of them
I I have a bunch
hey what do you think and he goes why
don't we pick three
and if I can get the schedule right we
could shoot these like three short films
we shoot three completely separate short
film completely different stories right
and then I fly back another day and I do
a Sound Stage day where I introduce the
show this is all just
proof I mean I don't have a good deal or
anything I just proof of concept
shoot these these 1.2 million what the
[ __ ]
how what yes Tom Segura revealed on his
podcast last week that he just spent 1.2
million dollars of his own money to
produce three short films they'll be
packaged together in a TV show-esque
format likely coming out very soon
welcome back to the joke World comedy
update every single Monday bringing you
all the common news that you need to
know from your favorite comedians and
your favorite podcast literally anything
happening in the comedy World on one
YouTube channel so please consider
subscribing to joke world right now
follow us on Instagram and go download
this episode on Spotify or apple
wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show 1.2 what'd you get for
that 1.2
make a whole ass I can make
three movies when um so we just did uh
color last week
color correction yeah and then we um the
mix was this week and there's a couple
of VFX things that are going and then
it's done I'll send can I send it to you
have you seen any of this do you know
that you're not getting oh no I've been
there no no no I've been there because
they're like we're doing color now and
you're like I hear the door I went I
went and uh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
no it's look it looks [ __ ]
unbelievable and I got like dude I got
[ __ ] I don't even know if I should
say but
who is a
he did one of the short he is
unbelievable so on the latest episode of
your mom's house Tom was talking with
Kevin Smith about how he's actually
written a handful of short films but
just hasn't had the time to produce any
of them it was until very recently that
he finally had a break in his tour and
was able to actually shoot some of these
ideas but even then he still didn't know
how they were going to turn out or more
importantly how much it was going to
cost out of pocket man like I I you paid
for it I paid for the whole thing 1.2
million yes you just told that story in
public yeah like where you're like oh I
accidentally paid 1.2 million for a
thing out of pocket change well
I'm at that risk but but I can't do that
I mean Clark's have been in business 30
years if a friend of mine is like I need
300 000 for a movie I'm like good luck I
don't know I'm looking for money too
where you tell me when you find
something you know what's crazy you're
like hold on
here's the crazy here Mommy yeah 1.2
here's the craziest for 10 minutes of
film we had an extensive conversation
about what I wanted to spend on this
thing right and it is less than half of
that yeah so it was agreed upon and then
one day I was like this is not what we
talked about it was it's way more it's
not exactly clear what he means by short
film I'm expecting it to be a comedy
obviously and I also thought of those
old videos that Tom has up on his
YouTube channel from like 10 years ago
if you don't know what I'm talking about
definitely check it out it's a mix of
like a short film and a very long comedy
sketch so I'm expecting something like
that just with 1.2 million dollars of
production value behind it oh
my God
[Applause]
Mr Mayor
baby boy drink with me Mr Mayor this is
Stan Ramsey from the budget office we're
using Stan for some healthcare PSAs he
was recently diagnosed with cancer God
I'm sorry Stan what kind lung I don't
even smoke yeah what did the doctors say
they gave me six months you know
something my aunt had lung cancer and
they gave her that same prognosis and
that was 14 years ago really she
remained cancer-free oh she died 13 and
a half years ago why are you telling me
this because it was like six months to
the day I mean these doctors they know
their [ __ ] it's a great meeting you Stan
hey indefinitely swing by before
April okay we can set that up through my
office
he hasn't given out any information on
the release date or the streaming
provider yet but I'll be sure to keep a
close eye on this and update you all as
soon as possible another reason to
subscribe to joke world and I got I got
crazy in the short as well I'm in all of
them but I only what I did was I wanted
to be in all of them but I only wanted
to be the lead in the one that I wanted
to be so right I thought I would just
lend myself to like I'm just cameos in
two of them right and the lead in one if
you're a tiger belly fan then you've
definitely been following the gang's
recent trip to the Philippines Bobby and
Company went down there about a month
ago to film and produce their very own
talent show I told also our highest
quality shirt and so it's the Kanye West
blanks so I was like [ __ ] I was going
all out Kanye West blanks we acid washed
it and we had someone hand distress it
uh distressed it and they also hand
stitched the stuff on the back
it's okay
all right yeah give me that here
download it on my thing I'll put the
whole photo let me ask you something
Jake yeah are there strip clubs here
yeah but it's sad bro there's no
high-end strip club
yeah
yeah I'm not looking for like surface
relations earlier today they posted part
one of their travel style Vlog that they
filmed all in the Philippines there's a
lot of great behind the scenes moments
with Bobby setting up the podcast with
Gilbert with fancy there's even some
kalila moments in there for you so if
you're looking for some more tiger belly
in your life it's about nine minutes
long and you can find that on their
YouTube channel right now Jay Leno was
released from the hospital last week
after spending 10 days in the burn unit
for those of you that don't know what
happened basically Jay Leno's very into
cars he owns multiple garages the size
of warehouses and he likes to work on
them himself so a few weeks ago he was
underneath one of the cars trying to
clear one of the gas lines when suddenly
it caught on fire the gas bursts out in
flames and severely burned his face his
chest and his hands to the third degree
hey Jay let me ask you this are you
nervous no no we got two shelves in our
regular and extra crispy okay I never
thought of myself as a roast comic thank
you thank you he took some pretty severe
damage from the room from this too I
mean he was in the burn unit for 10 days
third degree burns all over his body his
face his hands his chest it's a bad
situation but it looks like it's getting
better he's gonna make a full recovery
and hopefully he'll be back doing comedy
sometime soon guest spots from last week
your mom's house talked with Kevin Smith
two bears one cave was Burton Tom Tom
and Bert flagrant had on Neil Brennan
whiskey Ginger talked with Taran killum
kill Tony tonight is Tom Segura that
should be a banger of an episode and
Mark Norman and Sam Morrell were both on
Chrissy chaos we got wasted uh I end up
at a casino with stav and Ari shafir and
all I remember is we're we're in line at
this gas station stov led us to a gas
station he seems like it he looks like
an employee of a gas station
we're getting Fried Chicken Fried uh
your soft shell crab fried oysters just
fried from a gas station yeah
we're wasted and uh we're in line and
some some guy's just staring at the
three of us we're just glazed over and
he goes I know who you are I'm like when
you hear that you're like I'm [ __ ]
wrecked this is dicey then we're just
stuffing our face in our hotel lobby
chug just feeling disgusting and uh and
I'm so wasted at one point I just go man
imagine eating this [ __ ] sober and stuff
goes I'm completely sober what
stop wasn't drunk he's sober he's like
getting healthy well yeah because he
said I know he went to Baltimore uh for
the summer to go to like a fat camp or
something like that his brother's a
trainer so
[Music]
heavyweights this past weekend and
theophon had a solo episode for gangs
giving The Joe Rogan Experience talked
with Danny Brown we might be drunk at
unfortune fieemster are you garbage talk
with Sarah weinshank and tigerbelly had
on Mark Smalls as far as new stamp
specials go we have two brand new ones
that we have not discussed at all on the
comedy update so that's very exciting
starting off with Mateo Lane the advice
special that's out right now on YouTube
it's about 30 minutes long so it's a
very funny and quick watch we also have
Sean Patton coming out with a new
special this week on peacock titled
number one and according to that
description pen explores everything from
his OCD to his mad house of an
upbringing and the broken yet
unbreakable bonds of his family so two
new specials for you to check out right
there other than that comment some ones
that I missed for next week will be sure
to feature those that does it for this
week's joke World comedy update as
always thank you so much for watching
and we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news but in the
meantime please subscribe to this
Channel right now and turn on those post
notifications because on Wednesday we're
coming out with the best of November
funniest podcast moments from November
from all your favorite shows so turn on
the post notification locations because
it would be very very very very very
very very embarrassing if you missed
that video somehow or if you weren't one
of the first few people to watch it so
make sure you have those post
notifications on Wednesday just sit by
your laptop or your phone or whatever
you watch it on sit there and wait wait
for the notification click it right away
then click like and then comment
something for the algorithm because you
know how that's that's how YouTube works
you know that we need comments comment
something on this video too don't be
stingy with your comments don't be
stingy Mark all right thank you for
watching we'll see you Monday and
Wednesday best of November
foreign
[Music]